now we turn to the brutal weather
plaguing much of the u.s right now
millions of americans face extreme heat
today and it could be dangerous i mean
we're talking about triple digit
temperatures in some areas the heat is
complicating search and rescue efforts
in eastern kentucky after the worst
flooding in decades justin michaels from
the weather channel has the story
extreme weather has america's
infrastructure on the brink with the
eastern half of the u.s facing intense
heat and humidity today power companies
like new york's con edison are issuing
warnings that a massive increase in
demand could cause outages during an
extremely dangerous time
we're concerned about the consecutive
one day after the next of high
temperature high heat and high demand
and the stress that puts on the system
and in texas where unrelenting heat
keeps pressure on the power grid ercot
the state's energy supplier expects
today to set another new record for
electricity demand for the 12th time in
less than two months
electricity prices in the dallas area
are expected to soar to as much as four
hundred dollars per megawatt hour for
this afternoon
compare that to the average price over
the last five years fifty six dollars in
kentucky the sweltering heat is only
adding to the misery communities here
are working to rebuild crucial parts of
their infrastructure following last
week's deadly flooding i thought it was
going to be months before i could even
get out of here the community of
mcroberts crafted this makeshift bridge
after the original was destroyed by
rushing flood waters it's the only way
in and out of town
just down the road in the town of neon
the daunting cleanup effort inches
forward while residents try to pick up
the pieces if there's one thing that you
could get back that you know you can't
but if you could what would it be
my father's oil paintings
this is so sad when we spoke with tom
king his auto repair business had just
been deemed unsafe after sheer
devastation it's yet another setback
i've lost everything i had my whole
livelihood's gone
it's hard to imagine one week ago this
morning flood waters were ravaging this
small town neon kentucky in fact a week
ago right now i would be standing in 10
feet of flood waters there is more rain
forecast this weekend and back to that
small town mcroberts just to um our east
uh if the rain this weekend happens to
wash away that makeshift bridge
michelle the people there say they'll
just rebuild it again
justin michaels thank you well